as the Las Vegas Valley continues to
grow one community living in the shadows
is expanding talking about
King bayan's population it's rising and
for one it's a journey not a lot of
people really know about Christian
gossidas has more on the story of one
local man and a very personal Journey
we are moving forward it's been a long
and bumpy road for Frankie Perez the Las
Vegas resident inviting us into his home
to talk to us about his life as a trans
man how do you identify
so identify as Chicano as latinx as a
trans man sometimes I put that all
together and say translate the next
sometimes I say trans Chicano it all
depends on the space that I'm in that
space is important because he says
safety is his number one priority
growing up as a female Catholic and in a
Latino family his journey he says was
not easy my dad didn't say much to me at
first when I first told him he didn't
speak to me for a little while and my
mom she just she spoke to me but it was
very
awkward according to the Human Rights
Campaign there are more than 2 million
transgender people across the United
States representing all racial faiths
and ethnic backgrounds the word
transgender or trans is an umbrella term
for people whose gender identity is
different from the sex assigned at Birth
in Nevada there's about 12 700 trans
members according to the lgbtq center of
Las Vegas piercing Nieves is the youth
resource specialist with the center a
crucial resource they say for the trans
Community with their identity initiative
as well as a lifesaver it only takes one
adult in a Year's lives to save them
really and if they have that one
accepting adult or one accepting family
member it makes all the difference
definitely mental part first pronouns
right saying he him his I thought oh
well maybe I should have people call me
they them because I still couldn't
really get my head around like being
assigned female at Birth and saying oh
no I'm really a man gender identity as a
Trevor Project explains is not an easy
concept which is why pronouns matter we
may identify Susie as she or her but we
shouldn't assume that is what Susie
wants Susie may want to identify as they
or them Perez says it's all about
respect the beginning was just more like
okay these are my pronouns I'm going to
start
HRT which is hormone replacement therapy
changing my name Perez's journey to
transition began after leaving the Air
Force and finding the right doctors in
Las Vegas a private phase he says to
find his real self are you dating no no
no I don't have time for that today
Perez lives every day with a smile being
true to himself and surrounded by people
that support his decision a personal and
sometimes difficult Journey he says that
he does not regret taking I think with
the Latino latinx family
you know we go three things you know and
and we still get together Christian Casa
is eight news now
now Frankie tells us he's in the process
of achieving another personal goal he's
planning on becoming a father and he's
in the process of adopting so his advice
for others in the trans Community is to
be strong and really have a solid
support system